[Music]
so
i'm here to introduce you to what have
been done when we
went through the state of the arts
about explainability
so
i'm gonna start with a simple question
how many of you have heard about
explainabilities
please raise your hand
okay i thought you that's good
um a second question
is how many of you could name at least
one explainability methods
okay oh
quite much that's good
so
my ex my talk today is
we'll start with
the first question is
why do we need actually xai
because explainability we talk about
that we
don't
want to use it for the same reasons
so it's good to get a quick recap of
what we could do
if we have good explanations methods
first
the first
objective
is the one that most people have in mind
is
if you can
if you're in your autonomous driving car
and you see what the networks
inside the car is doing and you
understand what it does it gives you
trust in the prediction of the car so
it's quite useful to trust
what you're using
but it's not the only thing you can use
it for different things for instance
if you train the network and you're for
instance a data scientist and you have a
brand new architecture you want to know
if this
architecture is behaving well for this
specific task so you want to get inside
details saying okay i'm sure that these
neurons are
specifically detecting this kind of
thing so i can trust my network
so this is the second thing that could
be very important
but that's not that's not everything
it could be so useful for regulations
because
if you're
if you are a director of scientific
program and you want to know if you
could allow
this ai to go in production or not
you would like to understand how it
works
so
this is a different kind of explanation
because you want to see things as a
whole you wanna you don't want get
explanation for any
predictions you wanna see okay in
general this works or this doesn't work
but
this is slightly bound to the last
objective which could be understanding
and understanding
how
what
in which cases it couldn't work
for instance
models
learn biases
you might have seen the example of
detecting
dots and balls
and you see that the model is just
detecting grass and if it sees grass
it's likely to be a dog and if it is
snow it's likely to be evolved so you
want to know at least know the existence
of those biases
so you need xai to
explicit hospice
so
this is about why we need explanations
but it doesn't explain exactly what is
an explanation
actually
i would take a small time to read that
definition because it's one definition
of many definitions
actually the
definition of explanations is not a
consensus among all the
community
so
i took this one because it
reflects many important things that you
will find in many different explanations
methods
but this is not the only expansion of
the only definition you have
so
the
main many important words in this
definition is this notion of statements
this is the forms that your explanation
will take it can be text it can be
images it can be numbers it can be
figures
it has to be something that humans
understand
secondly you have the notion of causes
contexts and consequences
so it's it needs to be it's tightly
linked to causality you want to know
okay
for this
example
the methods the networks get these
predictions because of
for instance context could be
the grass or the snow
you can have the course that helps you
understand what is important or not
and you have consequences
say say okay i understood how the
networks worked so i know that
if it starts to wait or if it's
night
my car
might for instance confuse two different
things
so it's good to know
it can help predict what's gonna that's
gonna happen next
so it provides information
it's definite to domain knowledge so i
wouldn't give the same explanations to
phd or to a first schooler because they
don't have the same background they need
to have different
explanations things that people can have
and that complaint completes what they
know already it's something to be
interwoven with one another so it's
meant to be changed
between a model and humans but it can
also be exchanged between two humans
it's something that we could be very
meant to be exchanged
so now we have an idea of what
expansions why uh why we need it
i'm going to
do a very quick tour of what you could
find in explanations methods available
in the industry
mostly academic world so far
so a perspective to show how wide
methods could be
is to say we can explain different
things because i talk about model but
it's not actually a model it's just that
you take your data you take a diagnosis
and it gives you predictions so you can
expand our predictions
you can explain the model or you can
explain the data
first
if we want to explain predictions
the most common methods used to explain
predictions is called attribution method
so if you have for instance a set of
images you want to classify each image
images to say what is inside each images
one easy way to do is to ask answer the
question which are the most relevant
pixels in this image that helps to
verify to the classification
so it gives you something called
saliency maps
so in red you see the
most relevant pixel that helped the
network to provide its classification if
you remove all the blue pixels the
classification is still the same so it's
very important to see that the network
focus on the right
it doesn't look at the grid of the trees
or the grass as it could be
so now we explained models
because
this is very practical for end users to
explain predictions because they get the
prediction all the time but if you're a
model developer you want to understand
the model itself you want to say answer
the question okay
my model can explain
does
this specific neuron
respond to this specific
concept for instance
so one widely used method is called the
concept-based method
so you have your classes but you want to
check if both classes are linked to
concepts
for instance i chose
texture concepts
so you can say you want to say okay if
you want to detect a zebra
it might be helpful to be able to detect
striped
texture
so
this kind of method just take classes
and concepts
and your model of course and say okay
the
nero responsible for classifying a zebra
responds to this concept
or this concept all these concepts so it
gives you a big graph like this one
and you can read this graph by reading
the score of each concept for each class
so as we can see the concept of stride
has the score of something like 0.667.7
for the classic classification of zero
so
you can infer that if you want to
classify zero correctly
you need to detect the tribes
so it helps you understand how it works
inside
so we explained the model we explained
the predictions
and now we want to explain data
we want to say okay in order to classify
zebras or brown beers
what
is what kind of data did you see and
what did you kept from it
so one way to do it is called feature
visualization
it's trying to build from scratch the
most representative elements
for a specific network so you take your
network you take a black image
you take the neuron responsible of
classifying for instance the zebra and
you modify the image in order to
maximize that neuron and by gradient
essence it helps your brain
build
what is the networking dreaming of when
talking about
some specific classes
it really
gives you actually
very
specific images that shows that
what is
the network is seeking when looking at
some objects for instance if you want to
detect a butterfly
you see some wings so it gives you trust
that okay the network is
detecting wings in order to detect a
butterfly same for brown beers you see
holes you see ears
so it's see it forward so it's
it's gives you some interest into it
but this kind of thing is global you get
one image per class for a specific
network
so yes
it's a global view of what has been seen
in the dataset
and it gives you very interesting
information about biases because you see
in the image of butterfly you also see
a lot of
flowers and things like that
so it gives you some intuition that
if you take a bullfight put it in front
of a brick wall it's likely to be
misclassified because the network also
look at the background to infer the
class of the object
similarly if you look at brown mirrors
you'll see rivers you see graphs you see
things like that
so you understand that when the networks
got trained he saw a lot of images of
palm bears inside the river with crab
grass around
so it gives you an information which
could be very very valuable in order
detect biases and things like that
so
we still have three methods
one question could be
how many methods are missing and
actually
pretty much everything because
in our state of the art we isolated
50 types of methods
so it's something
if you talk about specific methods you
get something like 200 different methods
and it here's a very wide taxonomy
and if you don't know how much we did
we just explored these three so if you
wanna
dig
and explore more things about
explainable
ai
just look at all those different boxes
and feel free to dig
into it
because in the
time that will be left
and we talk about the limits and the
case yet of ai
xai actually
the first question
is
you get super
cool
explanation method and we want to be
sure that does it really reflects the
inner behavior of a network
so that's one question that people asked
and they did this experiment
so
on each line you see the explanations
given for
a
different method
all of these are attribution methods
and
for in the columns you just randomize
the networks
so on the left most images is the
original images i get super high
accuracy
and the rightmost image
just have completely random explanations
of predictions actually so what's
if if a random
networks gives random predictions the
expansion should be completely random
right
so this is the case for most of the
methods but what you see is two methods
that guided black prop and gated
breakdown gives the same explanations
so what does it mean it means that the
extension only accounts the image the
input image but it doesn't count the
model weight
so you have something called
configuration bias you see explanations
and you say okay it looks good so it
must must be good but that's not enough
you need something tangible to quantify
if a method is good or not
and that's why we use metrics
in order to get metrics you know a
matrix what it is it is something that
quantify a property of your method
you can explain the methods itself is it
fast can you explain animals that it
needs to get access to the gradients or
to the weight of your models
or just like a black box with its
predictions
so that's the kind of questions you want
to quantify
but you can also
evaluate the quality of predictions
so the examples i get you
sooner is an expansion showing some
methods are not faithful
they are good but they don't
reflect the energy of your networks
you also have consistency you don't want
to have the same expression to say yes
and the same explanation to say no
because if you get different predictions
it means you have different
uh reasons to do so
so
this is consistency you have robustness
you don't want the explanation to change
completely if you change just a single
pixel in your image
and finally
expansions are meant for humans
so you want to use to understand the
explanations because one way to explain
the models just give all the weights and
deal with that so but you have like
thousands or
billions of weights you wouldn't read
all of them and it's not individual you
need
something synthetic that you may
understand
and so you have
humans need to trust the explanations
so it's something useful to quantify
all these methods
some needs the
human
to be evaluated but some don't for
instance
a matrix called insertion and division
explain how much the model is faithful
or not
it's just based on several concepts
saying if you add or remove the pixels
the most relevant pixels
predictions must change very quickly
so
if you look at the graph on the right
you see that they remove pixel one by
one and see how much it hurts the model
of accuracy
so they should remove pixels and the
accuracy drops quickly to zero and if
they take insertion they start from
completely black image and they add
pixel one by one and they see that the
accuracy of the model gets very quickly
very high
so it means that
the model the method just focused on the
most relevant pixels
one important thing is that this kind of
method
evaluation matrix doesn't require humans
you have a protocol you have a final
number let's say it's good or not
so it doesn't require the human to be
evaluated so it removes biases it
removes confirmations biases
which is very useful
i know i think that one of the persons
who is online has this microphone open
so we can hear everything so
i'm doing the dishes i don't know so
[Music]
so quickly conclusions
what you should remember from this
presentation is that
first
we thought that
we would just explore all the methods
and choose the best one but there is no
best one there is different methods for
different use cases
some are designed for images some are
designed for
texts for some design for
somebody who have plenty of time to
understand it some
means to be very quick so it's very
useful to understand
in which scope the explanation will be
needed
who will need it why it will need it
so it's very important to design the
explanation use case actually
also i wanted you to understand that
explanations is not only
methods it's also
audiences who're gonna hurt who is
addressing
the
explainability who needs explanations
you wouldn't give the same explanation
to some experts who are gonna say okay i
am allowing this
methods to be put in uh this network to
be put in in that plane or to somebody
who just doing this shopping and wanna
understand why it is
suggested
something and finally one very important
aspect is the metrics you need
to be able to pick the best
explanations methods for your specific
use case
and this has been done on three
different
three different methods for instance the
first one would be very super
very useful for the end user
and the second one would be helpful for
model developer and the last one would
be helpful for the authority who want to
ado or not
model in production
so in
final words i just want to thank
everybody who helps us
on this task because
it was
quite a
large amount of work because
we went in a survey of surveys so each
survey was containing plenty of methods
so it was a lot of work and i want to
thank all
the people who just worked on that
and that's it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
uh i suggest that we move on unless
there is a very urgent and important
question to be asked but we have uh
yeah okay so let's move on i think
uh talking about the tools this time
i'm going to switch the presentation
thank you
so i'm very happy to share with you what
we have done in pasta
in terms of two state of the art or more
or
less
art
where we are today what we intend to do
that's what i'm going to
present you
if it works
[Music]
uh by the way
[Music]
thank you tibo for your conclusion
because
we begin by dance
use cases
types of data
methods and so on
in the sense that
well i'm an engineer
my job is to produce
the systems
and what i have to do is to produce
systems that are going to be used by the
user so
the approach that we have taken is
really a pragmatic one what do i need
in order to be sure that the system that
i'm going to develop is going to be used
um
so what's the process very simple very
obvious by the way that's what you said
uh demo
the first question that we that we asked
was the usage
what other different questions that i
have to answer in order to be sure that
my user
is going to use the system and for sure
one of them is
why you're going to
there can be also types of questions
such as why not
uh what if or things like that by the
way we
we
[Music]
[Music]
we identified four of them
as you did and we focused on two of them
first the end user that means the client
of the system
and also the developer the data
scientist for the data engineer who is
going to
to develop the systems
so
we try to find the different tools that
exist we identify the
well we tested
13 of them
and we try to understand also the
different types of explanations i'm not
going to go in detail but typically when
identifying that's probably for the end
user what is really important is to have
a local explanation that means okay this
is my case
what are you telling and
what's the explanation that you can give
for me in order to be sure that
that i agree on that
and probably for the data scientist who
is going to develop a system
to have a more global explanation so
we identified the different topics
for that
and also as you mentioned
the data types in which you are going to
learn and it's absolutely not the case
if we need a well for sure if we need to
have explanation on the images we're not
going to take a tool which is good for
explanation for the text and so we
categorize also the different tools that
we examined
on that
and
as it started from the in the project to
differentiate the the models that we
developed ourselves or the blind boxes
depending
on
methods
[Music]
[Music]
and so
what are the the results
i'm not going to go in details for all
the tools that we have made but as you
can see
we made with the same
protocol test
depending on the data
to try to observe the metrics or the
are the qualities of the different tools
and so we have tested the
certain tools if i'm
in which we have
identified whether or not they were
moderate agnostic or not either
providing global or local explanations
the types of models that we can
[Music]
[Music]
and what did we do
afterwards we put that in
our platforms for our data scientists
and finally for our clients and so
we chose three of them regarding the use
cases that they wanted to develop
we have integrated them by the way i'm
really happy to say that one of them
is coming from
the works that are done here in
this community and in this
community
so we have integrated them and we are
currently deploying that
then inside the the company through the
platform that we have used
and this is not the deployment is not
the easy part of
the theme because choosing the tool is
not so difficult by the way
putting the tool on the platform
either it's not so difficult but
afterwards
we have to present that to the data and
this we have to present that to the
clients we have to present that to the
that is the data citizen who are going
to make what we make for instance from
the specialist of that
and that's why we are currently doing
that and as a
recreation i don't know how to say that
i just propose you just to show you a
small
video of two minutes
just illustrating
this integration
and
i don't know how to launch the video
no it's
[Music]
it's a small video just for fun
[Music]
[Applause]
the presentation of oscar on the machine
can you tell us about your the feedback
that you had on these first experiments
how do people uh
are people satisfied with what you have
satisfied with what you have your users
etc
so
well by the way that's the video that i
wanted to share with you because we
applied it in the banking
use case
and by the way my
my first intent was to have an example
of a use case in order just to to share
for the data scientists and so on and so
on
so i didn't care a lot
on the validity of the use case from the
business point of view i just wanted it
to be credible
so to do that i presented that to the
banking specialists
and they were really really really
excited with that so they presented that
to their clients to the customer
because they found that really reliable
regarding first the
business
content which was
education
and
in the
interface the capacity to to help people
to understand
and to
add their i don't know how to say that
[Music]
okay so you can skip that's my name so
you can skip that's the director of the
project
and
also this one it's an enormous uh
quantities of methods and tools which
are being produced in explainable ai but
of course
is not only related
to machine learning it is a topic that
in artificial intelligence different
communities are
are working since many years
so you can go into this tutorial
and begin i was also saying
that uh
[Music]
this is exactly the same message that
was saying so there are plenty of
different of different uh users that
that have different requests for
responding so it's uh so the end users
and the engineers so we it can
especially be useful for the bathing or
for regulators protest that means that
any explainers
has also to have in mind the end user
i think that there is a
you can go
okay you can go next slide next slide
so and of course all of us
adore this community as a
big push for
uh
moving
transparency of the force
the
european regulators have in mind that in
some sense that the european regulators
they
establish a certain right of explanation
because
the recommended explanation is important
because
if you do not understand them how can
you defend yourself
in
any decision if you do not understand
this is a
against your right of being being defend
yourself and that's one big
big motivation as a reason
and i don't say anything in this
community because you know very well or
all the debate on the on
[Music]
uh so decision-making systems so what we
are going to have in mind is
those ex systems that at the end
want to
interact with the humans
to support the human making better
decisions so
and and they are being
understandable what has been proposed by
the existence it means that
the the humans
the humans can uh they are different to
different reactions that make people
humans interact with an ai system or
simply you you
demand completely the decision to the ai
system and in some sense your critical
thinking and it's a little bit
irritated in time
and or otherwise you do not trust both
those two extreme situations
are
not a success for reality if you do not
succeed to provide the autocrat way to
interact in an intelligent way machine
with humans so ei will fail so that's my
majestic next time
so uh go
go hold the animation please
so those are the motivation and this is
the
important point so my idea
my ideal vision of
why we should concentrate that why this
is so important
explanation
is that
the way i see decision super systems
based on
the machine learning
is that you have a shorter person which
is a you don't want to replace that
person so you want to empower that
person with the extra knowledge of the
best information my mother is dr house
dr house is a very important very
intelligent person he's there and his
collaborators are very intelligent ones
as well and they of course challenge
something and propose new and focusing
proposing new knowledge
and the success at the end that
the dr house is responsible for the
finances so there's possibilities in in
this idea so this is the model which you
want to pursue in
x-i in this project
please go ahead
next slide
and
what we are focusing and trying to
concentrate an explanation and an
explanation of pipeline
and
so inspiration is a human machine
conversation so that means that
the system proposes the proposed
recommendation
and then and then the human can ask and
contrast
such resolutions
or
other form of explanation and also the
user idea that can also try to sort of
try to remove to remove some features
and concentrate on others
and all that has been said so far all
the necklaces which have been so
they say the described so far are
small elements of these pipelines
again there is a
machine you need that you need a
method for explaining what the machine
is doing and then there is the user you
need a way to
explain also how the user reason
so that you can
you can
put them in contentious
explanation
which is only the beginning of the story
when what the user can really understand
please go ahead
so those are the line of reception that
[Music]
the rationale of the decisions so for
explaining the the in our case
we concentrate on machine learning so
for explaining the machine learning we
also have contributed to
some of the methods that have probably
been
being
by the previous speakers
but we need also the line which
concentrates on length
in terms of how to express now
know your explanations how you transform
these explanations in terms of
the demonstration which is uh produced
by one of those methods which may be
and that can be because
it can be transformed
[Music]
special or argumentation so there are
kind of different different way
so from the explanations what is the
language of this
the the language that you need to do
for expressing the
inspiration
then we have a another language is
watchdog platform
we also have a library a library of
methods because from data science this
is very important to have a benchmarking
environment where to compare the various
methods and
we started different dimensions or
other than those which have been
presented so far to compare methods
uh
and then
the watchdog platform assets and other
dimensions that's not the dimensions of
creating a space for a
experiment with the end users
and where there might be interactions
with the end user trying to understand
the way they reason
from the psychological
as a computational psychology point of
view also the
the way that the user is used and then
we have some of these cases again the
use cases are not made only for
validating demands of course they are
needed for that they are needed for
really
making operations
and
effective also if you don't have
very good cleaner applications with
complete vertical experiments very
you cannot really
contribute
but also it is a space where you have a
lot we are planning that
are already placed
experiments with end users and
to the aim of understanding
what is the impact in the cognitive
process of an explanation so in terms of
the decisions which has been taken so is
the decision
with without explanations different is
the decision
so how will this the question yeah it is
an important and important point because
i think that we have
we are facing now
a different uh situation with respect
the other doings or the
the
touring experiment
every now so
he it was
an external person serving two reactions
and uh
so the machine was intelligent is the
the
what you can say what the human being
observe is a distinction
now what we have in front of us is not
anymore a class which is completed by
the
machine now the task is completed by the
human in the machine so it's a social
technical system so we have to put in
place different way to evaluate the
system which are
[Music]
a combination of
personal professional machine population
and we have to relate that there's
something out of
this collaboration it's in any numerator
in my vision our vision
[Music]
there is also this kind of uh
there might be other applications this
is not the
there may be some conflict between
conflict between explanations and some
other ethnic issues for example privacy
so we want to preserve privacy but also
we want to have
might be some foreign
completing also
till where we can uh obtain and we can
uh
describe a situation for a person
without taking the risk of invading the
that you try this method as well in your
your
[Applause]
confined information
so can you go
next slide
so yes the
okay
up the previous one
the previous one
[Music]
okay this is the something which has
been already
perfectly
introduced so we have those two enormous
categories one is a postdoc explanation
and the other one is the
the explanation by design so
and then there are
interesting
topics of research
means that we stay with blackboards
and adopt explainers as a subsystem
which are capable
in a variety of different ways to
produce to produce a explanation in
terms of something which is partly to be
translated for you
or may not depend what is the background
of the humans that we are
learning from and
we can be uh
foster
can be individual not an explanation or
entire uh
inspiration let's
just say this is our mentors that we are
developing
which is
not too many i mean the way we compute
we compute the local explanations it's
similar to many methods essentially
what you do you use the you you you owed
it to the black box and given a point
that you want to spring you order the
black box until you generate an
improvement which is as nice enough the
number
and then you use the black box as a sort
of
audit and labeler so if it enables the
black box provide the labels for that
data and then you learn
[Music]
for example you may learn the decision
tree in our case we have a special
algorithm for generating the name which
is a bit better than others in in
literature but this is not the point and
the point is that
uh
we try to generate factual and counter
factor rules so with this idea that uh
your
mortgage has not been a problem
by what you can change for for obtaining
a different outcome and so
we are concentrating very much on these
content practical constructions and also
there there are plenty of challenge
because not all the content factors
[Music]
so there is an
interesting interesting area for
researchers on this corporate factor
it's a contrasting reasoning which is uh
i think it's a lot of importance for the
user now go ahead
so the next slide okay we usually
deliver this is uh
our champion
we use it in different context for
example we use it in the case of a
sequential data or health attract record
but the last thing is that in this case
the way we generate the network it's
using a medical ontology
so and that's very helpful if you want
to provide an explanation again fractal
and contractual explanations but this
time using using the medical ontology so
that the end it's easier to arrive to
generating natural language story which
preserved
the
order the order which is being important
in the sequence and also the
the significant part go
ahead okay then we also adopted lauren
in another context
this is another
another interesting area of research
just the license because i think the
essential young essentially going to
[Music]
and the things that
get very complex there so science maps
are expected but telling the story is
not very much important
so what we made when we try to
do explanation by exciters providing
providing
giving even an image providing
why and why not again
example content factor and content
of images but in this case
we try to simplify the same
using and using
output or vibrational colors compressing
essentially compressing the data in a
different space
learning learning the transparent model
in the
[Music]
space and then coming back coming
it is a very complex uh title because
so you learn enough important which is a
function of the sort of identity
function
and then on
this on a dataset and also you learn a
generator
this technology generation of the codes
allow you to do
this uh these two things
and then you of course you generate the
neighborhood in the latter space and and
then
as you can go back and forward from this
[Music]
and then
you use the generator on the ladder
space and then for generating a example
let's try this
this is just
very fast
to see
so what should be the complaints of our
method
various environments
the one which were mentioned before life
is having cement the gradient
so and essentially you provide the
improvise even even
this is a recognizing
digit so you provide a
similar similar image and then
and then also counter spatial images
images that for example
them being predicted the number four if
the image was done like in this part
but i don't know
we need to keep some time for the three
others
there's also this interesting
interesting part of going up in the
space
and i stopped here because i described
on the so there are plenty of results so
i mean we made this also we find serious
stopping
[Applause]
i want just to give you an idea of a few
things that
we are
so if you wanted
a conclusion message why i am
looking at the research presentation and
studying on the machine but you have two
minutes
you should go down but the final message
is essentially what i'm saying since
before is that
we are lucky to have this enormous
project so we can tackle a lot of
different damage but what is very
important is that
it's uh
you have to do the two modeling from one
side
you have to model the the machine
learning to explain the machine learning
media also to explain the users so and
then the two explanations has to import
so i think that it is the
the
measurement message so we need to model
the
decision-making process of the end user
for bridging or that we are providing
the appropriate
that would not be there for research in
psychology
so we i think we have to we can really
contaminate with other disciplines not
only not only
and the science imam is something which
is really computer science and
everything
and i i want to do something more
okay so um
thank you uh
thank you welcome uh
so i think i will be more on the side of
the
expansion by design
i will say that
we need scouts our modeling
[Music]
so you see we have a kind of uh
irrational exuberance about ai and
machine learning
because there are plenty of things which
are not really specified
and
the goals we can go
everywhere
and we don't know where it will not work
basically the promise of big data is
that big data can't stay
too big to fail
and we are starting to see the caveats
of this
about big brother
we would like to have something which is
fair which is a gamble which is
transparent which is robust
and basically to summarize i will try to
say that the um
uh
modeling is kind of
achieving this promise this is what we
will do next life is
hello
that's right
right so uh
well about the eye i will basically
speak more about christian learning
because this is what i know most and if
you have the fact that mission is all
about
building this feminine or genetic
modeling and that
discovery
they tend to be based on operations and
there is nothing bad about this there is
a fact that you can predict that it
rains when you see
umbrellas in the um
in the streets but next slide
[Music]
well the ultimate goal is to control
and uh
the point is that to make interventions
uh could be about health could be about
uh well whatever right uh and you see
the problem is that politicians can do
anything for you in order to control it
you know you can predict that the um
the number of nobel prizes in the
country is
[Music]
increases was the fact that the
consumption of chocolates of the people
but if you try to increase the the
chocolate consumption to increase the
number the number of local prices that
everybody would laugh at you
although you we can see that in some of
my countries there are public policies
which are
almost of the same flavor next life is
so i will uh try to say students what
kind of nutrition and now i will try to
save me
why cancer models are kind of say
remedy against this next type please
so because this is this kind of thing
you see you have a graph
and that's why uh
typically uh uh if you're when you were
saying that the subspace is so
terrible and that's why we i mean
speaking of
about a few dozen variables like that so
we do have a graph
and the parent
variable
is because it's the various process of
this variable
and then you have this kind of this
small thing you is the uh the council
mechanism
and uh and that's what you like and you
see those kind of small uh symbols dash
simple
with nice in there because they are all
the things that we know that we don't
know and we represent them with a with
noise
and
a console model would be that kind of
thing and i i i hope you would agree
that this kind of thing would be
accountable right because you can check
in usually using common sense that
something is your direct tools for
something else
next
oh great
and this is just the state of the art
right
very summarized in one's life you have
the fact that you can have uh very um
complex
uh
close-up mechanisms that that's the kind
of fi which explains how
the effect derives from the boxes
and
you have the scalability the number of
variables and you can see that we can
either have any variables or complex
mobiles but not books
and our was to try to be there in the uh
[Music]
yellow or
uh
rectangle and this is what we did with
the um the kind of suitable agnostic
modeling next time
watching
you see we are trying to
build a model
from all the others
okay
and then the good thing is that you you
can hypothesis to technical so i was
good but basically you see
the space of graphics is nightmare and
by this and by leveraging
the uh the
mechanisms then the hope is that you can
learn um
and
the council one so i'm going to get that
next slide and i will skip this as well
uh right and that will be closed this is
uh interesting
and uh
see what was going on i will try to
develop one first um application which
is about human resources so you have um
quality of life at work and you have the
economic performances of the the
perspective of concerns with that i'm
sure that your perspective from the
university or love is the same thing and
then the question is that those two
quantities many variables they are
correlated but what is the sense of the
causal arrow
this is the fact that when you are to
say happy and you are not predictive
or is it the fact that when you are rich
you can't afford to make people happy
of course you see this is a very
important question for how we are
managed right
so uh we got data a lot of data
and then uh we're actually
[Music]
and then we started to work with this
and you see what you what you find is
the fact that if uh
if you train people if there is an
information continue well there are less
work into it and the uh there are less
diseases okay so all all is well right
all of this is very sound next time
please but
this is a kind of disappointment because
everything is okay
well nothing confusing
so why it is that we don't find really
you know finding
well
one way is to understand this really
naturally is it like that there are
confounders
you have more founders the sister will
assume that you have one gene
if there was if they were one being
uh making you smoke and causing the
diseases you see them as all tobacco
will be born for nothing in the country
and then
so that would be profound
[Music]
which controls both the quality of life
of work and the performance right
okay and if you have a confounder then
there might be different causal
relationships depending on the one
problem so one of those is the activity
sector it might very well be that the
governor's operations are not the same
depending on whether or not in the
in the low tech sector or in the high
tech sector so wanted
to go on one
[Music]
so what we did was to just focus now
uh just a little bit enterprise and now
what we find was something what is that
really amazing at this time well we were
lying right but at least the other
students and the governors were very uh
say uh
well surprisingly uh i thought they were
fighting about this funding the fact
that in this long tech sector when the
salary increases then the productivity
increases
and when you are an economist you might
send the other way around when the
productivity increase you can afford to
increase the average child quality
so that's why we did in this sector and
of course we just squared the surface to
one piece
uh and then another um
another example i will give about the
it's about the relationship between the
nutrition the food you eat and the
health status
so the goal is that you know we all know
that we should eat five freedom
vegetables a day
but still the uh the diabetes
continues to increase the rate
so the question is whether uh can we say
something about the
uh to a particular person what's going
on and what to recommend
if you want to recommend you should you
must have
the um a causal model right if you must
retain just one thing from this topic
says this if you want to recommend if
you want to enter in
you must have not the predictive model
but the cause of those
right
so
we're going to be done
and what is difficult and you know
there is exactly the same diet in
england
and still the disease are very different
and the effects are not in there this is
the so-called cocktail effect effect so
we should have
plenty of room and complex inventions so
one minute
so we have
a marvelous takedown this is the
conversion that was in high
and then there was this come back and
then they just
so we had all this disruption you know
almost buckled
and then
of course
we got one piece
and then
what we did was to try to compress the
data you remember that you saw what you
were saying actually we assumed that
very very famous we have
the variables and we have them
is not so easy
you might have some languages at the
level of the quality
quite some that you have all the
molecules all the positions and the
speed
well there is not so much you can do
about a building model unit timing which
is a growth uh across um
abstraction type temperature for
instance right
so this is what we did with this
data food and we're trying
[Music]
with with cider and butter and cream and
so on
so we had
a an abstract discussion of what is in
the in the plate of the people who are
means excellent
and then we will say again we need to
have to be to thank uh ground
and great
about the interventions because we don't
have enough
uh data
not enough statistical power to be able
to see what happens when you press
bishop with chicken okay or both of
those muslims
so what we were doing is then
where what edge to replace so this is an
interaction you replaced all the
products and the basket of food
after household with organic food
okay so one thing
[Music]
so
you define this intervention this is
what i said and i expect this
and uh well in this data those were from
2014 so not many people called us were
kind of interested in norwegian
improvement you can see this in a lot of
states that most people are not
next
and now
you see
that actually there is a difference
so the blue is the general people the
thing is the people eating
and you can see that the distribution of
the bmi the body muscle tax weight which
is supposed to be a
relevant leader of the health status is
different but
it might be the case that this is
because you know people eating already
[Music]
of this confounding effect
so
one
and then typically we would see that in
some parts of the population you can see
that there is actually a real difference
between young people and the rest of the
people and you can see that the
difference is really significant
on the bmi which is all we have
so this was an example
of i would say a real thing where we
and uh
okay yes it is just beginning of the
story and by the way this is the
shameless
announcement that we are having so
please contact me so because you see
once you know how to predict if
the failures okay in this instance
again
then the question is whether you can use
this model in order to repair the things
it will simulate my own and there is
also something which is something right
now again and proportion was invited
which is uh
just great to me
you have to pesticides we know more than
ever uh
the calendar of when they are in defense
and all over the place we know a lot of
things about fact that if you are a
scientist if you are in say before you
were born then if you are trying to
smell this
and precise uh time steps of your
development
then your problem
or water
mechanisms will be impaired
and then the question is getting data
and the
level of mission whether we can find
them
so
uh
okay i'm done thanks
[Applause]
as usual i need
one minute to do the
presentation switching so you can still
talk for one minute
is anyone wanting to ask any question to
michelle yes okay so here we go
um can you say a little bit about that
uh method that was it did i understood
a graphic gnostic method for
constructing
your causal model uh i didn't really
understand that part okay oh great so uh
no we can't do that
okay so again
so uh i mean that you try
to learn at the same time
one graph
to predict
each variable from the others
right
and then uh
okay there is another conversation done
so that you can use ask you
um as few variables as possible right
and now based on this product estimation
of the individual example okay you can
predict valuable insight from all the
others
right
and now this allows you
to generate the things inside
and you can do this for all followers so
now you have plenty of data which are
fit
which are set by one variable
and now you
install the discriminator so this is
exactly the same mechanism as the
generative personal network and this is
when it is trying to discriminate the
fate from the truth
and by that way because loss
is trying to make each
mechanism protecting the variable from
the others
as good as possible
right
this is why you can learn all the parts
of the graph at the same time
yeah hello everyone i'm pleased to be
here to share with you
a few
recent results achieved by my research
group
at australia
about the student trees and explanable
ai
so the the very starting point of
work
was the following claim and quite common
you can find it in a number of papers
decision trees are interpretable
and implicitly other machine learning
models typically unknowns
and so we're interested in determining
to which extent this holds and to make
this
save a bit more precise
of course this requires first to
emphasize what interpretable means
and
of course it is a big issue we are not
going to circumscribe
here what it means precisely but we
wanted to
identify a number of conditions a number
say of necessary conditions
in order to consider that the machine
learning model is interpretable it would
be useful
to be able to address a number of
say xci queries
from which we can derive from useful
information for two purposes mainly
[Music]
the predictions made by the predictor
on the one hand and also being able to
achieve some verification dust okay to
go inside the model and especially to
check whether
the the predictor as it has been learned
actually comprised with the requirements
that the the user or the experts may
have
about
the classes for instance
and of course
just identifying those except excel
queries is not enough what we really
want to get at the end
is some algorithms and if possible some
efficient algorithms okay being able to
um
so that we can actually address those
queries by running those algorithms okay
and efficient like the reasons
for for us it will mean tractable
polynomial time algorithms
for being scalable
and in the following i will focus on
boolean classifiers but this is actually
just for the ease of the presentation it
is not
really important the results can be
lifted to the general case easily
because they concern complexity aspects
and so by considering decision trees now
just because decision trees are known as
the intersection
of machine learning and knowledge
representation okay
decision trees are an old and popular
machine learning model
i mentioned on the slide
an old
quite well known papers by ross quinlan
published
35 years ago in the first volume of the
machine learning journal
okay and this paper
has been cited a lot more than 25 000
citations for this paper
of course as you surely know there
exists many implementations many
extensions many applications of decision
trees more recently for excel purposes
we consider decision trees as surrogate
models we try also to use them as a
target for knowledge installation
okay so
decision trees are not so bad of course
from the pure prediction point of view
they are usually not very accurate
in fact not very stable not very robust
to noise
it is interesting also to note that
decision trees are also interesting as a
knowledge representation but that's why
we want to represent
instance bulletin function and with some
colleagues some years ago
we actually investigated decision trees
as kr model and actually identified a
number
of the properties offered by decision
trees decision trees appealed as quite
tractable we can
in fact
associate with decision trees a number
of
tractable algorithms to
address queries related bullying
functions and to achieve transformations
also related to the grammaticians
so it's quite a good candidate
in the following i'm going to present a
few extra queries four time reasons i
will focus only on three queries two
explanation queries and one verification
queries and to illustrate things
i i will consider this a toy example
here on the slide with these flowers
but the purpose is to recognize command
body arts in in french the rose premiere
from other roses by taking advantage of
four
features
the fact that
the plant has a deciduous foliage
has a heart-shaped lips has large
flowers and has a light green stem
okay so very simple
here is a decision tree okay for
recognizing such
common bodies
so i guess that everyone here knows what
the decision tree is
so i'm going to switch this one maybe
more interesting is how to use this
predictor
okay to uh return live with a given
instance like the one
here
where we consider a plant with deciduous
foliage but it has no heart-shaped
leaves no large flowers and no light
with them
should this then be recognized as a
common hollywood
the answer here is not how can we get
this
simply by following the parts
the unique path in the tree that is
compatible with the values of the
attributes here is the instance
okay
x2 must be formal x1 must be true and
three must be false we
at the end we get
zero leave so it means that this
instance is not recognized by the
predictor as a common value
okay so the question now can be why okay
and uh
in the following we consider two
explanation queries for instance why
this
particular instance is recognized as a
common audio so explaining why but we
can be also interested in explaining why
not i will explain this a bit later and
there is also a number of verification
queries i'm not going to get into the
details i will just uh actually talk
about one specific very verification
queries so
for verification queries we do not
consider specific instances
we consider the predictor
by itself they will want to determine to
which extent it complies with the
expectations one can have the
so to say expert knowledge of user
knowledge
okay so briefly explanation queries we
typically uh consider two kinds of
queries additive
explanations
that that are about the why question
okay and control factual explanations
that are about the why not question
so often when considering objective
explanation focus on the minimal ones
the
logically weakest
explanations
and so we want to determine a minimal
subset of the characteristics of the
features with corresponding values
from the given uh instance
and we want to
be sure that every instance sharing
those characteristics will be classified
precisely as the instance
the instance we start with
okay so for instance here
if we want to explain why in the
instance one zero zero zero was
considered as a common value
okay
um a sufficient reason is that this is
because of
x2 that is false and x3 that is false
okay the the fact that x 1 was equal to
1 and that x 4 is equal to 0 does not
matter here
ok this is the precise meaning of what a
sufficient reasoning is
and we can be also interested in
counter-factual explanations for that
case we're interested in
the why not question so basically the
user or the expert is surprised by the
answer provided by the prediction made
by the predictor
okay and he would like to determine a
minimal subset of characteristics such
that if they are flipped in a given
instance okay the the corresponding
class the corresponding prediction will
be flipped as well
and for instance here
if you just flip
the the second feature in the given
instance okay then you will recognize
the command for you
while the the the instance we start with
was not recognized as a common value
okay we can
actually check this here
okay if you flip the second
characteristics
so x two will be equal to one so you you
follow
the bus
on the
right branch and then because x one is
equal to one you get the one leaf and
one leaf means that the instance is
recognized as an element of the class
the positive instance
okay
so in a
previous work published last year we
defined a number of such queries
explanation queries and verification
queries
[Music]
and
now so why decision trees can be
considered
or usually considered as a temperature
of models
typically this is because one can find
an abductive explanation for easily even
any instance just by following the
classification technique following the
past in the tree starting from the root
to the leaf
okay and for instance here
the direct
this this kind of addictive explanation
that is sometimes called direct resin
for the example here you can just
explain why
the instance has not been classified as
a common bodywork by considering
the fact that
the
features x1 is set to true and the
features x2 and x3 are set to false
actually the value of x4 is not
relevant here
okay this can be computed efficiently
the point is that this reason is not
is not a sufficient reason it is not
minimal okay
in fact you can
[Music]
remove some some features some
characteristics in those explanations
while
keeping the same
property okay
and
in fact in a
very recent paper it will be published
next next month
what we have shown is that those
previous xi queries
listed on the slide are all tractable
there it is polynomial time algorithms
for all those excel queries when the
classifier is a decision tree
okay so quite good
for instance if we want to get
a sufficient reason from the previously
direct reasons you can easily use a
greedy algorithm to derive such
such
reason
what about the other families of
classifiers in fact they turn out to be
far less interpretable than decision
trees regarding the set of excel queries
for which they are tractable so in the
same paper we have considered a number
of other ml models that can be
considered as a view as a representation
in specific case of coolant functions
and we have shown that all the previous
excel queries are in fact
interrupted by npr for those families of
them
okay
finally our decision tree is a panacea
for the explanation purpose
not completely okay limitations exist
and uh there are two major limitations
as two explanations
on the one hand a given instance may
have exponentially many sufficient
reasons so focusing on one of them is
not enough for sure
and those
sufficient reasons maybe
totally different one another
okay
so computing a single sufficient reason
is not enough
i'm going to skip those
guys and finishing with this one
okay the construction is a bit theory
oriented but we have made also some
experiments to see what happened in
practice so for instance on this
well-known data set or separating four
unwritten digits for an island
okay we have learned decision trees
using the standard platform and
scientific learner
we get
we actually got a decision tree was
quite a good accuracy
and you can see the instance on the on
the left
outside of the slide and for this
instance
it has more than four than 400 billions
of sufficient reasons
put on the slides also
some two of those
reasons and as you can see they are
quite different
okay so just computing one sufficient
reason
clearly this is not enough
okay so i i will finish now there is
solutions to synthesize the set of
sufficient reasons but of course i do
not have time to present them here
okay
thank you thank you
yes yes but
yes actually this is not the end of the
story we
there exist techniques to synthesize
those reasons and we can we can do
yes we can do better and we can also try
to exploit knowledge especially user
knowledge the model of a user to get
actually better explanations and to
synthesize also the explanations that
will be the next step of
my research
i'm very happy to hear that
pragmatic view of explanations is
catching on it's something that uh i've
been advocating for quite a while
um
finally i've written up a paper on this
um yeah explanations are pragmatic acts
and so of course
they're going to vary from person to
person that needs what it's a what do i
mean by pragmatic act i mean that an
explanation is a response to a question
by an explanation who has a cognitive
problem why did something happen for
example you put something in a liquid
the liquid turns blue
i might say why did the liquid die in
blue because my beliefs aren't
sufficient to determine an answer to
have made that prediction and so an
appropriate explanation the part of the
explanation that does the explaining
should tell me uh what's
what to do with my beliefs and fix them
and in this paper uh 2021 um
my colleagues and i uh actually
formalized the pragmatic uh approach
and we give a game theoretic analysis of
its complexity
okay um i think i'm going to skip these
slides because i think it's pretty clear
uh what we're doing here for explaining
a model i'm going to talk mostly about
models-based explanations about the
predictions
[Music]
um
and uh as marquis uh pointed out yes
we're interested both in counter factual
explanations added abductive
explanations and we publish stuff in
2019 and 2020 where we actually make the
tie
between the
tight correspondence between
counterfactual explanations and
abductive explanations and uh joao uh
marcus silva one of the people in the
idt team
uh has been one of the pioneers in using
a prime implicant based uh approaches
since 2019 with several nerves papers
[Music]
okay so there are lots of different
systems
we've heard
and i want to say a little bit about uh
heuristic methods about model agnostic
methods because uh
you brought that up and a lot of methods
aren't in that case
and i want to remind you that anita is
in the business
of making ai work for critical systems
so if i want an explanation in that
uh
critical system in my airbus 350 if my
virtual co-pilot
uh tells me something i want an
explanation for why uh he's telling me
or it's telling me
to change my flight plan
uh that better be a correct explanation
what do i mean by that okay so let's
take a look at some of these uh
standard model free or model agnostic
explanations how do they work very
roughly the idea is that you have a very
complicated underlying system um
like the kind of benjo is talking about
and you approximate it with a simpler
one maybe around a local decision okay
so there's something in here
that's implicit about counter factual
explanations and counterfactual models
but what is
wrong about these approaches is they
don't actually
systematic systematically take into
account the notion of a counterfactual
okay
the problem is that the explanation
there's really no
guarantee that the explanation is valid
let me just give you an example so at a
local point
it might be uh let's take me oh this
isn't really me
i can't use best call either okay
imagine somebody who's uh
wants to know
you know why you got the home well
you're 45 years old and your salary is
uh 50 000 euros a year that was good
enough to get the loan okay those are
the features that lit up in the future
now
um
that's
and okay maybe that's those are the
features that are relevant in that
instance but actually
uh there that means that all other
things are taken as being equal now
let's move to a different space in the
location
and these two things are consistent with
another decision no and we find these
actually happening in these agnostic
systems okay
so
the two features that i've isolated are
completely useless it's not even an
explanation so what i want to
concentrate on here a little bit of
something that people have mentioned
someone michelle uh certainly
which is what's that modal relation
between the exponents and the exponent
the thing to be explained in the thing
that does the explanation
okay well one way we can do it uh is to
translate uh
the machine
the implemented algorithm into a logic
formula
and we can uh get such a subset uh
minimal
sets of features together with the
logical encoding of the machine that
entail the prediction
and we could use a variety of different
logics
typically in ipt we've been using uh
usually fragments of first order logics
and here's the the sort of map of
results that we have up to now that
we've improved through 2019 and 2020. so
knight batteries classifiers other
linear classifiers are polynomial time
decision trees polynomial time
monotonic classifiers polynomial time
these are all good results for um
boosted trees
well let's take for example decision
list and random forest where where the
worst case analysis is um as well shown
in
2020 uh you know non-efficient in
practice we do very well
okay
now for uh deep neural nets and asian
networks we have scalability issues
and it's no accident as i'll come back
there are hard complexity results out
there both for causal models
which are an amplification of beijing
networks and for logical models
okay just you know we've been pretty
active on the xai front in logic um you
know so
uh you know we've got this
uh seven acr papers we've this is a
difficult field to crack because logic's
not really in fashion uh right now
um
but uh
we're trying to make the point i think
we're getting the point across that yes
logic is an important ingredient for uh
explanations that are valid because if
i've got a logical proof of the
prediction there's no way that the
features that i've isolated plus the
encoding of the machine cannot give me
that prediction okay so that case that i
gave you for the heuristic explanations
just doesn't arise here
okay but what do we do about scalability
well
um you know we can think about
statistical relevance that's what
machines are good at that's what uh they
capture
and there is a very interesting notion
and i was just talking in the uh in the
lunch break um
lots of people hear about a similar
notion that we can do with uh with uh
subset minimal uh
explanations and logic
and this goes back to something that
wesley salmon said in the 80s namely
that you can't get an explanation
uh that's using statistical relevance
but you have to do it relative to a kind
of partition of
the space namely you have to have
homogeneous partition and what does that
mean that means that
you isolate your features and if you add
any more features if you try to divide
up the classes anymore you don't get a
difference in the probabilities okay so
there's no variance
and there's his definition uh which i
know we're
short on time but basically he's
exploiting that homogeneous partition
okay
um
so how do you get at this homogeneous
partition that's the hard question
well what you need then
is something like a bayesian network
or a causal network
that's great but we already have these
results i don't know for 10 15 maybe
even 20 years
to try to
get a
get a causal network or bayesian network
from data automatically it's np hard so
we're not it's not going to be something
that we can really do
in practice
at least not with any efficiency there
may be special cases and of course as
michelle is saying if you've got the
causal model you're golden that's great
but if you don't have it you've got to
learn it
that's very hard
okay now one of the things that's very
interesting and this i'm going to touch
base just a minute uh
with um
uh
jessica's talk
camera yeah
is the um of a counter factual model
one of the things that's very
interesting about uh
about counterfactuals is first of all
they have a logic
uh this was a logic developed by david
lewis in the 60s
a philosopher
but they're also very closely linked to
adversarial perturbations
so if you think of your data space
um
you know as an x and you now think of
some maps uh defined over this space
uh the space the map might
shift only a certain number of features
those necessary to get a different
prediction from a certain point okay
that actually defines a set of counter
factuals that are true at that point
and every such map uh defines such a
set of counterfactuals and every seven
counter factuals to find such a map
and that needs uh so yeah so we can
actually build these maps by adversarial
perturbation techniques and it's pretty
efficient but more interesting is we can
move
from maps between individuals to maps
between sets of individuals so we can
just lift it right on the power set
uh it's a standard operation that we use
in logic and
set theory all the time
and we can now talk about a map between
two distributions
okay
[Music]
and
then we all of a sudden have a new tool
at our disposal another way of defining
counter factual maps and that is using
transport methods methods from
statistics
so what's cool about counterfactual
models
for me and for most of us in mit is they
build a bridge between
statistics and logic
and causality because david lewis
developed the theory of counterfactuals
to
express causation
okay
now
so then if we have a map between
sets of individuals or over
really now probability distributions we
can talk about
transport theory and transport of plans
and like all the other maps i was
talking about these two define a set of
counter factuals and they have a logic
so we can link back to the logic
um
[Music]
now let me bring in causation at the end
okay
okay
[Music]
okay
well michelle has already mentioned
causal networks or structural
counterfactual models from uh pearl and
glenmore and so on
and uh just as i said inferring uh
patient models is the pigeon networks
are complicated so too are these uh
structural pattern financial models we
can't infer them uh it's another
endpoint problem
but
if
we have certain causal networks
like this one
[Music]
where we have a single valuedness
assumption
which also has a logical counterpart and
we have this uh idea of no hidden
confounders and so michelle's a word
will show you that this is a substantive
assumption
at this point we know that a structural
counterfactual model satisfying sp
defines a kind of transporter operator
and
then we have this theorem that was
approved by a dissertation student
two of them actually and what it does is
it says that under certain conditions
you get the same set of counter factuals
from the transport map
as the causal model
and this causal model has to be a
particular kind it has to have
these uh these properties
why is this interesting other than just
being beautiful right now we've just
learned
a
deep theory about mathematics
uh
statistics and logic well that's pretty
but what does it do for us well you can
find these transport labs at least in
certain cases in polynomial time so you
bypass the whole
uh uh exercise of trying to build a
structural console
okay so i think that's uh really it i
mean i really like the logical methods
we like the logical methods in 90t
because they give us provable approvable
guarantees
but they're difficult to scale up and
there's this result by coutinho and
others so it's a pretty amazing proof
that shows even for binary classifiers
solving a general problem of getting a
minimal uh
subset minimal
uh explanation is uh np hard and even if
you try to do probabilistic stuff around
it it's still np-hard with a function
from a probabilistic like polynomial
class into the npr class
but finding good statistical
explanations is not really any easier
yes you can do
these approximations
but i told you that's dangerous at least
if you're going to put it in your airbus
350.
and so what i think is
very interesting and i think what you
know we have to offer in iot for coffee
house and for these industrial
is to find these links between
relatively efficient ways of building
counter-factual models that give us both
logical record
uh in the
at the end
and some kind of tractability
[Music]
[Applause]
what should we do
are we going to solve these problems of
complex of complexity
of the
different
possibilities of logical research which
are not applicable to numerical systems
and
possibilities and
things that we can do in european
systems so what is your view on that
michelle and nicole i want to say okay
oh i say something yes because um
uh i do think there is yeah i think
those intractability results are not
going to go away
but look we've been faced with this
before uh think of the automatic theorem
proving uh realm
uh people proved amazing theorems with
people-assisted peer improvers okay
and
all over the place
how do we what do we what what is their
secret well it's interactive it works
with a human now if you thought about
doing explanations
in an interactive way building
proofs in an interactive way and
distribution aware way
um
that seems to me to be a very promising
uh path to pursue
um
and you know we're following in the
footsteps of giants because you know we
have we have amazing hearings that have
been improved uh through interactive
fear improvers
you shared for scott do you want to add
something on that
i have to admit i'm very fascinated by
this
that the theory the transportation
theories that may be the bridge between
statistics logics and
but i think this is very fascinating so
we have to find a way
so it's
because we need the theory behind behind
all the things that we are going to do
so
i'm fascinated by this uh
theoretical framework that i mean
it's behind you improving and it can be
really applicable to
that there are also other lines that
they
[Music]
[Music]
yes um
so
uh
uh
i think that we are okay so i think that
the distribution between the
proofs and
say the empirical results
is generally
very interesting
and also very fruitful
so uh of course this is exactly the
decision which
[Music]
[Music]
suggesting that when you want to make
something work
then
you you start with engineers and then
you have to gain proofs afterwards
so
of course because
[Music]
people who like proofs
we tend to say uh nothing practical like
a good theory
but nevertheless i i should say that we
should not uh adhere
um to the magic of proofs you know too
lightly and then if i
the treatment test is to find the twins
and the turbo condition in the treatment
movement in the uh in the cultural room
and i was wondering whether this is can
be true in terms of transport
we haven't really considered that but
certainly you know we think of
we take the calls along very seriously
so we're thinking about uh do
interventions as linking the two uh
distributions to the you know map to go
one into the other and uh yeah what you
suggest makes makes good sense that's
something we should think about thank
you
i mean well thank you i
don't want to dig into this too
seriously but it's really you know as it
was really very continuing
um
so so what what was exactly the question
real question um therefore whether we
can hope to have explanations which are
stage credible
or efficient or
no i i think that the
transformation was
what what would be the trade-off between
the these two approaches
between the
statistical methods and the logical
approach and providing explanation i i
think that this is my it was my
understanding of the
question but that
is no more here to come on the questions
it's just wrong he's taking the
logistics there
i i have the mic because i have
i have a kind of comment on
the way we are approaching this position
[Music]
nicolas gave my favorite example then
you have a kind of digital assistant in
the cockpit recommending to the power to
make it left in for five months for
example and the
the pilot should be attracted to his
question why should they do that
especially if
he or she has in mind to do something
different
and so this is this is just a break up
the
the distinction between
explaining afterwards and explaining the
real time
which are to me
two different things in some sense yeah
so giving explanations of justifications
for uh why the system behaved
the way it behaved or
or recommended you do something it's
different from
providing an explanation in real time
which is which which in in many cases
you have to bridge the gap between
the safety and points the same items
that
identified for explanation and then the
british are between this and the
language which has also to be used for
explanation because explaining is not
just tracing things and you have to
provide language which is understandable
by the by
and it has to be in real time i mean
because the complexity
the complexity issues you have mentioned
nikola saying this is polynomial this
it's it's crucial issue because if uh
computing an explanation
takes
more time than what is required to take
a decision so it becomes just useless
and even and irrelevant and even
counterproductive it has to take into
account the
the cognitive load and this the the the
stress the state of stress of the the
the the operator of the user to whom the
explanation is provided and we are
talking about critical systems here so
all these issues have to be
taken into account to be really
pragmatic
in order to if we want to
to provide and to have solutions that
are really usable otherwise you will be
providing a list of
formulas or whatever you want if you
don't bridge the gap
between this and the
the way that the accuracy will receive
the explanation
okay this is this is just my comment
maybe just a very small comment to a
piano
the the solution you have
presented reminds me
a very
insightful work that was done by kaplan
in on cooperative answers on why a
cooperative answer why an answer how
what are the
the reasons for which an answer is is is
void for example if you ask questions as
how many students succeeded in
in
in their exam in june session
in instead of saying zero so we say
there was no joint session
and this is the same the same approach
that we presented for decision trees and
i just recommend if
[Music]
[Music]
you want explanation
before the before the decision
but you see if the complexities the
conflicts are born
then
this is definitely not
asking for an explanation there is a
very nice uh moment in um
when he was in spain in the in the 36
when he was saying that
when they were
receiving an order from their
saying
and you know this is a bit surprising
when you are in the context of the world
so
um
when this is really critical
and i should say that before is this
then typically
i don't see the point of asking for
explanation so uh if you have the time
to ask for information you are not
really in front of the machine again
this is one thing
or idea or perhaps this is just my life
but
the uh the point is that the magic
criteria decision adds systems which
have been developed
for young for worry for critical
say
occasions
they have simple
simple models like design
right so you are you are ready to accept
the tradeoff that you need to kind of
degrade
the
complexity of your model in favor of
letting the person appreciate so because
you give an explanation
so
if the point of an explanation is to
allow the person not only to be
satisfied but to change the decision
then typically the expansion should be
uh something different
right it should be more like a more
complete moment
okay that's that's all i i apologize but
i have to to leave him
[Music]
i was just going to say one thing i
guess i'm not
totally agreeing with michelle i think
you know if you're a pilot and you know
you're doing planning here um you
definitely want your explanation and it
does have to be in real time
in order for the virtual uh pilot to be
of some use and so i agree with david i
do think there's also a hole but your
question does open a nice area for
research which is a posteriori
explanations where yeah okay so there if
you're thinking about you know why the
model do this you're not under a time
constraint yeah then we can then we can
look at uh things
you know which are you know
you know algorithms that are indeed i
don't see any problem with that
[Music]
very early on in the national ai
strategy on in france the issue of trust
in complex systems and the combined ai
modules or components
or with critical ai applications uses
attention
because these applications and uses
corresponds to the french industrial
base
and even if nothing is set in stone and
if this industrial race may want to
evolve or the preposition itself and
even if the government's economic policy
is also too encourage a very dynamic
system of smes and startups because the
contestability of markets and they are
able the arrival of new players
even when they kind of accept
established players they would think
growth actually
but these issues are paramount and this
is why the royal defeat was created and
we are happy very happy
that he associates a very large number
of french industrialists and
the audience here today was very
numerous
research structures and more
particularly two technology research
institutes the systemic and subject
library
institute
which
something to do which welcomes us today
we are currently finalizing the
framework for the fourth
investment program generation
which will run until 2025.
it is not up to me
to continue to communicate on these
measures to the political level
but i can tell you that we are working
hard on the issues of trusted ai
to extend the actions of the quantity
and also to deal with a particular way
with the issues of specialized hardware
for ai the hardware software pairing
embeddability and frequency
and also for another research program
it's also important
that we anticipate the future eu
regulation act
although still at an early stage of
discussion but it has begun with the
member states at the council
although we must ensure that the balance
will be stricken between regulation and
innovation
innovation in ending enabling sandboxes
that need
to fit
the iterative nature of ai developments
it's complicated not
to set everything in advance so
regulators have to understand this more
clearly
it's very important that sandboxes allow
some uh some sort of interaction with
the market
this uh important regulation acts will
bear on the critical systems defined in
an intel index sorry annex ii
and on the sensitive for human rights
systems listed in the next week
it may seem a bit far away but it will
be a grand challenge to precise norms to
stabilize evaluation letters and to set
procedures at the institution in such a
short
time and similarly the french air
ecosystem
like most ecosystems in the technology
in advanced countries
is marked by a very rapid
and even proven take-off of ai
and as a result
a shortage of talents is perceptible
which stabilizes
your recruit your recruits ability
which stabilizes the markets and which
also slows down the potential of ai
diffusion in our country
and this is not only true for the
segment that makes most headlines in the
press like data science but it's also
true in data architecture
it's also true in data preparation and
was very happy and
it was very interesting for me to listen
to the second workshop on this
management
and also the production on the
professional production and management
of the entire life cycle of systems and
ai software developers
so we will need to focus on this also in
the years to come and i'm sure some
announcements which will come soon about
that
and on school of course we will need to
develop the multi-disciplinary skills
express ai
that need to come with the experts
to conduct hybrid approaches and i know
how this is important and i know also
how to have in mind that
ai is a broad set of techniques and not
only
the number of training courses and
people trained and people retrained has
risen sharply since 2018 and the
quadrupling objectives formulated by
president macron
but we are far from being able to meet
the demand of the sector
so we need to further accelerate
and also
to bring
public training closer to the needs of
companies without sacrificing
long-term objectives with science but we
need to have more matching between the
two
and finally we are also convinced
that we must stop considering the
ethical principles which are essential
very well defined and framed by the edge
level
line of work at the un level
as a checklist but that these principles
they sometimes can be contradictory we
must announce this and sometimes the
legal people who don't
know much about ai they try to cover
their checklist
and they should remember that as a
constitution
uh which is a set of contradictory
principles it is the same we need within
there but it's a question of balancing
of developing approaches of reasoning in
proportionality and of making
sound arbitrations appropriate to each
field
each context and each category of
technology
so i would like to thank everybody for
this very
cool and studious uh
today's actually
and i'm very glad that uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
i'm gonna shoot my favorite
thank you for being here and crossing
these two days dedicated to
threats of cra
i wanted to underline the in your
presence
the key role of the government
in the conference the telling program
and in particular the grand defeat
on a transfer car for industries
the country succeeded to mobilize
at national level
large industries
laboratories
research institutes startups and also
smes
to face to transfer issues
the quantity proportion and also
federator
around the strategic roadmap
computer daily program
isn't completely part of this rom
also is completely implicated
in the implementation of this this
roadmap
and participate to the realization
as you know transfers is true
that cannot be played only
at national globe
here too the government and the grand
defeat
lead the way of solar sourcing at
european level and also international
level
so thanks for that
it was a pleasure to attend this today
and i hope
this pleasure was shared
i would like to warn you thanks all
participants
and look forward to see you
for the next edition thank you
[Applause]
hello so i am here to give the best
buster award
[Music]
winner
but first of all i want to thank you for
this very active exchanges between
all of us and all the topics we have
covered i think it's
inspiring and providing some
interesting uh takeaway
and in article in the name of the team
so i would like also to thank the teens
for preparing
all the days
in terms of the best poster award i
understood the race was fierce
i think it's also representative of
now we have 14 posters i think
so many challenges but the indian
representative of the complexity of the
task we have
we are taking actually
but
he's one winner and so the name is
thomas
[Applause]
[Music]
the
delgady
is this one is active learning uh
better sorry i don't have my glasses
then random selection for really
really what
the task
which does not surprise me because i i
do believe
it can be a game changer
in
some industry and the
visibility so thank you and i think you
have
a book
how humans judge machines so as you can
see different thoughts i guess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
i switched to english
but i'm really
really delighted for having been here
during these
two days which was the
the first
public event of confidence.ai
as i said when i was
interviewed a little bit earlier
this program is really essential for
french industry
and hopefully for european industry
it's essential but because it's
accelerating the journey of
ai technologies
to
real applications for critical systems
the program is
expected
to deliver
tools methods processes in order to
design develop
even certify
ai-based solutions it's one thing to
design and experiment algos it's
completely different thing to bring
these argos into real applications and
this is why this program is is is really
important as is unique because it's also
the only program
directed to ai for industry so it's it's
very important even if the ecosystem is
with industrials with academics and even
startups and smes who are also joining
the program now so it will have
a real impact on our economic
ecosystem
i think that uh
with with this kind of program i am now
confident that
france and europe
is really in the competition of of uh
for one of the the global competition
of ai based applications and
technologies
what they have seen during these two
days
making me really confident now we were
just wondering
will we be able to
use this kind of collective intelligence
in order to
come up with something which will impact
our economy and our society and to be
really
well
uh to to to be really
a leader in in critical systems
using ai technologies so
i think that we are on the right way
yeah
i have a
strong hope and of course expectations
uh for the coming years of the program
i think that
all of us here will come back in our
companies in our research institutions
with some
positive messages
saying that okay now there are real
concrete things that are uh coming out
of the program
and
probably that
the
what have been doing uh with this
uh consortium here uh
will uh probably also um
uh draw the way and and the path uh
toward a kind of horizon now
where we are building
a world we can all trust using using ai
technologies and other digital
technologies
thank you all thank you for having me
here and
thanks for the organization which was
really
very very well i would say
well nothing is perfect but it was
almost perfect
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you